ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from our temporary studio
it depresses me so much how
the audio only episodes of the show do
not perform well on youtube even though
they're really some of the best
content you know the podcast i just did
is one of the best i've ever done and
it's hovering under 300 000 views
because there's no video
they're so much better when they're just
audio it's all meant to be audio it's
not meant to be this this is all kinds
of force by the way okay
it's crazy to me that people but i
understand we live in a visual culture
and i do enjoy the visual episodes and
you know the visual aids that i have to
show you look this is what i mean and
but
listen to the last episode i did it it
was recorded from a car
driving through texas and it's better
than many of the video episodes because
it's not really supposed to be
a video medium but nobody cares
intent
and intention don't matter
uh
to the people that watch this show
they're just they're addicted to visual
they don't really care what goes on
austin texas
how austin became one of the least
affordable cities in america
big new york times piece
on my
favorite
city
bar
none
the capital of texas
how austin became one of the least
affordable cities in america the capital
of texas has long been an attractive
place to call home but with an average
180 new residents a day
its popularity has created a brewing
housing crisis that is reshaping the
city
180 new residents a day
60 of them comedians
that's wild
how many 200 people a day
moving to austin texas why
no one knows but they're coming
over the last few years in one of the
fastest growing cities of in america
change has come at a feverish pace to
the capital of texas with churches
demolished mobile home parks raised and
neighborhood haunts replaced with trendy
restaurants and luxury apartment
complexes it's a big gentrification
project is what's going on
the transformation has perhaps been most
acutely felt across east austin
and the neighborhood of montopolis
a 2.5 square mile patch southeast of
downtown where unobstructed views of the
ever expanding skyline have made the
historically black and latino
neighborhood a sought after community
well you know who's coming
white people
white people are coming
white women
and white men are coming to
live in montopolis
so they can get a view of the
ever-expanding
google skyline
in austin texas i of course live 30
minutes away from austin i'm not even in
the county i have nothing to do with
this
i have displaced
no one
i bought a house from a guy who was a
retired cop but he retired a long time
ago
and and the wife and they were white i
am displacing nobody nor have i ever in
every city that i've moved i've never
really displaced
any of the indigenous people unlike
uh many of my counterparts
in comedy and elsewhere
uh they
have all the right opinions online but
where do they live
they live in these areas that have been
historically hispanic neighborhoods in
la and in new york they've been
african-american neighborhoods and
people come in
and they just don't care and they move
into these apartments and they tweet
black lives matter from a room
where a black family used to live
so
it's a weird
cognitive dissonance many of them have
because they are the problem but i'm not
an anti-gentrification guy i understand
that there are positives and negatives
to it but i've never done it
i'm exempting myself i lived in hell's
kitchen
and then i lived in astoria where
everybody it's it's a multi-ethnic
paradise in queens i never lived in a
trendy hip i lived for two months
in flatbush brooklyn
with a crazy woman and uh the house had
no garbage because she was afraid of
rats and it was her room in my room and
my room did not have a door i just had a
curtain and this crazy woman
uh
would put a garbage bag and tie it onto
the
um
door of the kitchen and she said we can
out of a garbage because of rats she was
terrified of rats apparently she saw a
rat or thought she did in the apartment
and from then on she would never have a
garbage and
every day she would take uh three bites
out of the north eastern corner of a
piece of toast
and then put it back in the refrigerator
every single day
and i would see it as i went in to get
almond milk for cereal i would see the
which is three little bites like a rat
like a rat would do
and me and her had a
falling
out and
she wanted me to leave and i don't even
remember what the falling out was about
i just remember she wanted me to leave
and i said i want my security deposit
back
and she goes well that's not the way it
works and i said well it is the way it
works
and i forced her to give me my security
deposit back and she made me meet her in
a drug store in brooklyn a small drug
store in public because she was afraid
to like meet me at the house you know
and i took the security deposit back it
wasn't a lot of money i think it was
like a check for 750 and i just i just
screamed very loudly at her it
embarrassed her in the store i said
you're an animal
as i was walking out i said you're a
goddamn animal
and uh i wish her well
uh for two months but that's it but
every other place i've lived i've never
ever once lived in a gen and i'm not
saying that everybody who lives in a
gentrifying area
uh
is a demon
but
you know i i'm i there's something about
the energy of those areas i don't like i
don't like these trendy areas
and
a lot of those areas it's like white
women with gang art
like that's the aesthetic it's like
white women gang art
and i to me that's not for me i i like
to go out to the suburbs i like the
suburbs i really do cities are hellish
truly
as i've grown older i've started to
realize that when i was younger you
would like the cities but then you live
in the cities and you go
the suburbs are nicer they're better
there's more space
right
there's not a ton of people with their
ideas
everyone has an idea suburbs people just
go hey shut up
get takeout
instead of
assaulting me with your ideas get
takeout
take food from that restaurant bring it
to your house and eat it
so when you feel like talking about the
things you believe in
stuff it down with food
so when something is about to come out
like well you know what i really
put a calzone in there stuff it back
down that's what i like about the
suburbs as opposed to the cities where
everybody is tripping over each other to
let you know all the things they figured
out
they figured it all out that's why they
have three roommates um and they get
high
uh and they're 40 but they figured it
out in the cities
and you know what's coming now
and we're not going to spend too much
time on this article in austin uh but
let i do want to read this
we knew it was coming
said francisco nunez
irish
who for nearly two decades lived at the
cactus rose mobile home park
until it was sold to a developer to make
way for amenity-rich apartments that now
fetch more than double what he once paid
in rent
the cactus rose mobile home park a
decade ago austin the capital of texas
often deemed a liberal oasis in a
staunchly conservative state was among
the most affordable places to live now
according to a forecast prepared by
zillow a real estate company that tracks
affordability the austin metro area is
on track to become by year's end the
least affordable major metro region for
home buyers outside of california it has
already surpassed hot markets in boston
miami and new york city so i mean listen
and i see people on twitter quoting this
article and they're like we did it
we did it
you hate la you've made austin a
shittier l.a
thank you elon musk and joe rogan
and google
and all of these people telling you how
great it was to move to this hot
uh
insect infested
swamp
known as austin
look at this lovely couple
they lived in a mobile home park
and that's what should happen they're
enjoying it they have nice plants they
look happy yeah they're happy
and then what happens elon musk goes uh
oh don't look at me
and then he goes we're gonna move to
austin and then joe rogan goes we're
gonna make the biggest comedy scene in
the world and then all of these people
move to austin well then what the hell
happens
they get kicked out of their mobile home
cactus rose mobile home park to make way
for high rises that will be filled with
demons
austin is the worst kept secret
says job hammond
j.o.b
job hammond is this person's name
with the university of texas flagship
campus gentle rolling hills and a
vibrant music scene let's unpack all of
this briefly
okay
the university of uh of texas flagship
campus is is an utterly meaningless
statement
that's let's just get that out of there
let's get that out of the way the
university of texas flagship
like we mean business at this location
gentle rolling hill what are they
talking about it's for stupid people
gentle rolling hills what
i don't even know what that means
and a vibrant music scene that is not
true
it has no music scene
literally none
austin has been an attractive place to
call home long been an attractive place
to call home but surging prices have
created a brewing housing crisis that is
reshaping the city of nearly one million
people and pushing mostly low-income
black and latino residents like mr nunez
away from cultural centers
transportation hubs grocery stores and
other amenities what they're going to
need to do is build affordable housing
they're going to need to build
affordable housing
that's what's going to need to happen
i'm calling it right now
they're gonna need to build affordable
housing for all these people that are
getting displaced
do you disagree with me no i agree
i think they should build affordable
housing yes
because you can just say that yes to get
out of any conversation
about this you go like this you go well
there because this is what people in
austin do everybody's sowing into
brisket you go oh they're going to build
affordable housing
affordable housing is coming
well i understand your concerns but
uh for we need affordable hou there's
gonna be affordable housing for the
nunes uh family
um well i'm glad you asked there's
housing coming and it's going to be
affordable
so the nunes is no no listen listen to
me
stop freaking out
stop it does it it's of it's affordable
housing is coming no they're going to
build housing like for regular people
except they're going to give it to to
them for less and it's going to be
affordable housing
do you not get it
affordable housing so what i'm saying is
i'm not worried about any of this
because they're going to build
affordable housing and everything's
going to be okay my recommendation is
you not move to austin texas
um because
there's truly nothing to move to
and i'm not i'm not insulting i don't
even live in austin texas i live outside
of austin texas
i don't
i've walked around austin texas i've
driven around austin
i
for the life of me
don't know what
people are talking about and i'm trying
to get on board
but i can't get it through my head
i don't know what they mean
about the vibrant music scene and
the only thing they've got is shootings
if you like shootings
if you're into shootings
do you like shootings
google austin texas shooting
they love shootings
[Music]
oh yeah
man killed after shooting in northeast
austin
three people shot during two separate
south austin shootings
one hospitalized one arrested
after shooting in austin entertainment
district and who's being entertained
police investigating late night shooting
near ut austin
man shot inside of 6th street tavern
says he will be okay after shooting
isn't that nice
they go they go how are you enjoying it
here he goes i love austin and i'm going
to be okay
don't worry about it man shot in in west
campus austin police search for a
suspect man critically injured in north
austin shooting at shopping center
from soros to unions the left poured
major money into everett to defeat
austin's police staffing proposition
fox news article not not quite a
shooting but maybe related
so that's really what they are it's the
it's the live shooting capital of the
world if you want to see a live shooting
and a lot of people do because music is
boring but if you want to see a live
shooting
if you want to see someone get killed
go to downtown austin because it is the
live shooting capital of the world so
you hear the banjos going and the guitar
and then you're gonna hear what sounds
like a snare drum but it's shooting
maybe that's why everybody keeps calling
it the live music capital of the world
because they're confusing a snare drum
with uh an a gun
that's not a drum it's gunshots
who's this uh well why are we looking
him up he was a famous uh one of the
most famous mass shootings was at the
university of texas they got started
early no
charles whitman he had the tumor in his
head and he was sniping people from the
clock tower on campus so they have a
long history here we need him back
well let's get out of here
everybody needs a vpn everybody the
government's trying to kill you
everybody's trying to market you things
it's better to to make sure that you
control who can
see
your information online
anybody can hack you a smart 12 year old
could do it your data is valuable they
can make a thousand per person selling
personal info on the dark web
why use expressvpn there's an encrypted
tunnel that creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between you and your device and
the internet hackers cannot steal your
sensitive data it's super secure okay
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption it's easy
to use
fire up the app and click one button to
get protected works on all devices
phones laptops tablets and more so you
can stay secure on the go
you use it all the time it's so
important for us i would never not use
it anymore because if you don't use it
the people
are they're going to come and get you
so i think it's good to have it to
prevent people from stealing your
information
and then really
what's to stop them from finding out
where you live and coming and getting
you you're tr it's true it is true
expressvpn.com
tim dillon you get three extra months
free are you kidding me
expressvpn.com tim dillon three months
free
expressvpn.com
tim dillon we need a way to secure and
protect our online activity
i love raycon wireless earbuds i i you
know wireless earbuds
the the other ones no one likes them
and raycon is the last of the most a lot
of people are switching back to wires
but i the wireless raycons are still
cool they come in a bunch of different
colors everybody loves them they're less
than half the cost of other earbuds uh
they're great they're a great gift
they're great for you they have six
hours of playtime you don't have to
charge them every two seconds there's
five stylish colors you can pick a
perfect one for everybody on your list
this is great holiday stuff holidays are
coming up faster than you think now is
the time to knock out that gift list and
avoid the last minute it's great you
know what you get this is the year you
get a few little gifts
you don't get the big gift right because
you're not going to get it supply chain
get a few little gifts and little
stocking stuffers raycon earbuds are a
great stocking stuffer
go to
buyracon.com tim
buy raycon.com
tim and use code holiday
today to get 15 off your entire raycon
order that is by raycon.com tim use the
code holiday h-o-l-i-d-a-y
to get 15 off your entire raycon order
by raycon.com
tim
because you know what's coming now is
the flash mobs now i've i've uh warned
of this uh many many uh moons ago
i was on the record talking i think
about flash mobs i'm unsure
now the flash mob is not nearly as fun
as it sounds what it is is a gang of 20
or 30 people and they run into
nordstroms which would be fine because
no one cares about faceless
corporations like nordstroms right kind
of but they they beat the people in the
nordstrom so that's not good so the
flash mobs come in and they're not you
know a lot of people try to make them
out to be like fun
you know theatrical events
where people are just kind of like
striking a death blow to capitalism by
grabbing a few handbags but they're
beating the people at nordstrom's
they're attacking them they're hurting
security guards they're hurting people
that work at nordstrom's it's not good
and seth rogen thinks it's good
seth rogen thinks it's good and seth
rogen do you know what he did recently
seth rogen drove
a few people over to casey neistat's
house to rob his car
seth rogan is facing backlash after
downplaying youtuber casey nastat's
experience with car theft uh casino stat
has children he had uh a pinata or
something in the back of his car
something like that party favors
decorations so yeah
all right so
somebody robbed them yeah here i got the
thread right here and and casey was uh
unhappy and he tweeted to our cars got
robbed this morning because los angeles
is a crime riddled third world [ __ ]
of a city
well that's a lot but hey
he goes but tremendous appreciation and
gratitude to the hard-working officers
at
lapd west
who not only arrested the [ __ ]
but they got all of our stolen goods
back so that's casey neistat taking the
terribly popular position of uh calling
out la for being crime britain and then
also saying hey uh thanks to the cops
which a lot of people do not love
hey thanks to the cops and then seth
rogen says
um
dude i've lived here for 20 years you're
nuts haha it's lovely here don't leave
anything valuable in it in your car
right in it
it's called living in a big city so seth
rogen's whole point is like hey man
relax
and casey goes i can still be mad though
right i feel so violated
seth rogen goes you can be mad but i
guess i don't personally view my car as
an extension of myself
and i've never really felt violated any
of the 15 or so times my car was broken
into once a guy accidentally left a cool
knife in my car so if it keeps happening
you might get a little treat so seth
rogan is high as usual right he's always
high right that's his thing yeah he's a
drug addict he's like a weed company he
likes drugs there's nothing wrong with
it he's addicted to drugs probably
i i mean there's nothing wrong with that
but that seems to be what his thing is
right he sells weed he's
so he like doesn't care about people
right seth rogen would be robbing cars
if he wasn't an actor probably that's
kind of what this comes down to seth
rogen's like hey man i'd be breaking
into your car if i wasn't uh uh an actor
who was a funny guy
and seth rogen's made some great movies
but
you know i think seth rogen's kind of
like i i
um
really like
empathize with whoever stole your
daughter's
party decorations out of your car
because frankly i would be doing
something similar
had i if i wasn't a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire
he seth is kind of example of a guy who
seems to have run he's run so far to the
left he's in self parody he's it's not
even real anymore like he's unable
to
make a point that doesn't descend into
some type of parody because he's so on
another planet that i understand people
going casey you're overstating it la is
not a third world [ __ ]
most of it might be some of it is but
not all of it right you can't say all of
it right
and i understand like says rogan being
like hey man that was a little bit much
but then seth rogen be like i don't view
my car as an extension of myself well
what if someone put a gun in your head
and made you get out of it
and they stole it
because here's the deal
seth rogen doesn't need to view his car
as an extension of himself because he's
rich
see rich people don't care about cars
because they can get new ones
they can uh you know have a driver pick
them up it doesn't really matter but if
all you owned is a card now certain
people all they are now this may
surprise seth rogen i'm sure wouldn't
i'm sure he knows but all certain people
own is a card now casey neistat is not
one of those people
he owns more than this is why it's tough
right yeah sure it's tough it's like the
comics who are commenting on me and
michael che it's like two guys with a
lot of money upset at each other and
then some guy eating rats being oh one
day who's gonna win
[Applause]
it's
some people just have a car so when your
car is broken into to some people it's
not nothing
it's something
i remember when i when all i had was my
car and i would do cocaine and get in
accidents and it's upsetting
when you are coked out of your face and
drunk and you smash up your car and it's
all you own it's a big deal so i could
only imagine how i would have felt if
someone broke into it because i was
devastated uh at uh when i smashed uh
totaled five cars and that was very sad
but
seth has to understand that that not
everybody has a real estate portfolio
and
projects they care about
you know seth is lucky like we're lucky
we get to do something we like we have
projects
and people care about projects and
things you get to see come to fruition
things you can start and pour your mind
and body and soul into and then and then
love and and and curate and then see
them go from nothing to something their
movies and books and whatever and um not
everyone has that some people literally
just have a chevy cruze
and they they sp and they're proud of it
and they work their ass off for it so if
somebody walks by and smashes it and
grabs their [ __ ] out of it they're gonna
be upset
and i think california and they
california
has problems with uh the crime
and now you have the flash mobs which
the flash mob thing is um
smash and grab it's the old smashing
crap we're back to the 80s
the smash and grab is you smash and then
grab and you do it in uh large numbers
so sometimes there's people in beverly
hills sometimes they hit a nordstrom's
they hit these uh department stores or
sometimes they go into a store they
smash
and they grab what they can get and
they're out
and every now and then a security guard
or an employee gets in their way and
they [ __ ] them up
and that's not nice
um
now some people go
hey
what's the problem like seth rogen types
would go what's the problem
with
their kids having fun now they're not
kids but this is probably the refrain
from the you know the people that you
know they go what's the big deal i could
even be persuaded
hey a flash mob here and there i think
is fun
it keeps everybody on their toes i don't
necessarily think it's the end of the
world
a flash mob here and there
a little flash mob here and there keeps
you going but
it's becoming a pattern of behavior and
it's becoming troubling because innocent
people that work in these stores are
getting hurt
they're getting smacked
beaten up
they killed some dude i think i don't
know but they're they're these flash
mobbers are
they're out of control
and
the whole thing here is civilization
clearly doesn't work perfectly
and there's a lot of people out there
going well if it doesn't work perfectly
maybe we should just get rid of it why
do we need any of it
why can't you run into a store
kill a security guard and steal a
handbag
is there a good reason for that
well there's a few
you shouldn't kill an innocent person so
that you can get a gucci handbag
and this is anarchy which a lot of
people seem to not mind right it's it's
anarchy if you are uh
shopping
and all of a sudden you have to duck and
cover because 30 people have run into
the store to smash things and take
that's lawlessness and some people go
what's the problem
seth rogen i've never viewed nordstroms
as an extension of myself
it's lovely here what's the he's just
hiding in menswear what's the problem
so what
30 people that are armed have entered in
nordstroms to [ __ ] around and take some
[ __ ]
so i guess
that's the attitude but
i think most people are starting to uh
get a little tired of it last friday a
mass smash and grab hit luxury stores in
union square in san francisco and the
next night in nordstrom in walnut creek
in the east bay 80 people jumped out of
a pack of cars just before closing time
and swarmed the stores aisles many
escaping with merchandise two employees
were assaulted one of them with pepper
spray
then
shortly after midnight last sunday
culprits used a sledgehammer to smash
storefront windows at a louis vuitton
and a saks fifth avenue in beverly hills
police said but patrol cars arrived to
scare the thieves off before they could
go inside
at the grove in la's fairfax district
this week the nordstrom robbery did not
appear to be deterring shoppers
guadalupe rivas extended a 12-year
tradition
of trekking from bakersfield to the
popular outdoor mall on wednesday for
holiday shopping the day before
thanksgiving she was enroute to meeting
family in fullerton
what who is writing these harder this is
so weird she said the smash and grab
robbery was not gonna deter her i quote
i've never felt scared here and i wasn't
gonna let that stop me
here's what i love they they gotta put
in like
like the pro yeah shopping message
always you know
the smash and crabs did not deter the
brave guadalupe rivas
who drove from bakersfield
to stare down these anarchists herself
if need be
she was going to the grove this is her
12-year tradition of going to the grove
and buying [ __ ]
the day after thanksgiving
reevas quipped i might ask one of them
to help me with my bags she doesn't give
a [ __ ] hold on let me read it said riva
shoved to several boutiques and said she
felt secure with guards protecting
entrances to nordstrom's in the apple
store a pair of lapd officers all were
also posted at the police kiosk
and riva said i might ask one of them to
help me with my back they shoot her
immediately
she's like is there any way we can
she was a flash mob
it was a mob
oh the employees were not allowed to
comment
nordstrom employees say they were not
allowed to comment about the robbery in
referred questions to a corporate
spokesman
in a statement the company said quote
given recent incidents at two of our
stores in incidents across the country
we've been heightening our in-store
security presence and implementing
additional protective men here's the
problem folks if you if you
if the whole attitude is let's get rid
of the police is it fair by the way is
this advocates of the workers out there
i know uh you know many of you hate
watching this is it fair to take the
police
their job and give it to the hourly
workers at nordstrom's
should they be the ones handling
this problem
does that seem fair to you saying let's
get rid of the cops let's let's place
all the responsibility on these people
at nordstrom's
who are getting pepper sprayed and
beaten
because you know what happened the the
stimulus is over the coved stuff's over
and people are out there
and they're excited
and they're getting uh
and they want to commit crimes
and they know that you know this is a
great climate to commit crimes because
as soon as you commit a crime
seth rogen will defend you no matter
what it is
so when you have
celebrities coming in to defend you you
go i think this is a great idea
who cares
let's go let's grab some merch over at
nordstrom's
have you ever shoplifted
no i never have never once i guess when
i was like three i stole some uh
colorful band-aids i wanted to add fred
flintstone on them why would you steal
them at three i i wanted them my mom
said no and then i had to bring him back
and i was crying and i never stole again
she caught you and what did she say she
was like very bad she was like very very
bad we're going back to the store why
didn't she just get you the band-aids i
was probably being a piece of [ __ ] all
day i was probably being nasty you were
not a good kid i don't think so and very
few people liked you
i've spoken to family would poop my
pants all the time no you were a real
piece of [ __ ]
literally and figuratively
but what i'm what i'm uh saying here and
uh is that um
now why don't we do i'll do it could we
do a flash mob in like a fun
flash mob in a froyo place and just
still the froyo from yeah the toppings
like something fun where we don't pepper
spray maybe we pepper spray
because that comes out right
maybe we pepper spray one of the young
girls working in the froyo just don't
get it on the toppings you don't want
yeah you i would pepper spray her in the
eyes
and then i would steal the yogurt and
then seth rogan would defend me
that would be my hope
[Laughter]
if we could make something like that
happen
then
but i used to steal a juice i stole a
fresh-squeezed orange juice every day
from the food emporium for two years on
eighth avenue uh in new york city before
i got on my tour bus
and one day
uh one of these guys who just got out of
jail who's like a
do-gooder caught me and he was working
at food emporium
and
he goes i'm catching you he goes i just
got out of jail and he's like and he was
like this he became a rat
he became like this
like bad person awful who got out of
jail and was now ratting on people
and he hated me and i hated him
and
i stole that a juice i would steal a
pizza at this place suburban eats which
is a deli in melville long island and
i'd eat it on the line while i was
paying for my sandwich so every day i'd
eat a slice of pizza very quickly
and by the time i got
by the time i got to the cashier i would
only pay for my sandwich because the
pizza was gone so i did little things
like that
but i never did a flash mob
you know
how do you
how do you get into a flash mob
how do 30 or 40 people
some of these are 80 people they really
have to organize here it's
truly kind of interesting
80 people
you know what it reminds me of the scene
from ghost uh not ghostbusters um
the scene from uh batman where you know
jack nicholson walks in and they're
wrong oh yeah the boom boxes and
everything in the restaurant
well
i'm just saying if you're going to
uh do a flash mob
think twice about it
think twice about it because
uh you don't want to hurt an innocent
person and you shouldn't steal
it's wrong
everybody it's blue chew [ __ ] omnicron
it's all about blue chew get the dick
hard get it moving get it
blue
jew
it is a penis thing
bluetooth unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in a chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost you
could take them anytime day or night you
can plan ahead fuller empty stomach
doesn't matter blue chews medical
professionals will approve you online it
is very quick that tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package i
love blue chew we all love it
the best part it's all done online no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy blue chews tablets are chewable
you can chew them like a flintstones
chewable it's fun it's nostalgic you can
be ready whenever you need to you could
just pop a tablet in no matter when the
opportunity arises has to be consensual
now
try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code td at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's b l u e c h e w bluetooth.com
promo code td to receive your first
month free
visit
bluechoo.com b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w-choo.com
td promo code td
keeps you got to keep your hair the best
way to keep your hair is to stop it from
being
taken from you by a vengeful god
keeps is the only hair
loss prevention system
uh that is
very cost effective
it allows you to keep your own hair you
got to start soon it takes four to six
months to see results but it's discreet
the results are proven
it's got a ton of great five-star
reviews people love it
i mean they deliver medication straight
to your door every three months you
don't have to leave your home
all of these things are incredibly
important
i mean i have friends using this and
they're so happy about it because you
know two or three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 more than 50 million men in
the u.s suffer from male pattern
baldness there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
so it's low cost
it works
you got to start soon that way it'll
keep the hair you have and if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim
dillon to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com tim dillon to get your first month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
unusual symptoms
of mutant covid restrained south african
doctor who first raised alarm about
omnicron warns its early signs are mild
and patients who not lose their sense or
smell so they shut down again this was
like the biggest story omnicron
omicron whatever they called the omicron
omicron the new covet variants here
uh fouches like lockdowns are not off
the table israel shut their borders
other people are shutting their borders
it came out of an hiv patient in south
africa right that's what i've read yeah
they're really they're really pulling
out all the stops for omnicron they're
like let's give it an origin story
it came out of an aids patient in south
africa they were like what failed with
the other ones you're like they didn't
have origin stories give omnicron an
origin story okay say it came out of an
aids patient
oh okay
omnicron has since been detected in
britain germany italy belgium botswana
israel hong kong and australia while
australian health authorities are today
conducting an investigation into a
suspected case now south african doctor
says this is like a tempest in a teapot
it's a storm and a tea cup he goes
listen guys who cares
the symptoms are very mild it is maybe a
little bit more transmissible but like
every virus there's a lot more mutation
mutations and it weakens the virus over
time
but nobody wants to hear that but isn't
that what you're hearing too that's what
i'm doing this was a this is not
the end of the world this is not what
people think at all this is going to be
absolutely fine i'm hoping it's a false
alarm and the market rebounds and yeah
because the market got slaughtered
everybody thinks that uh you know the
plague is here
but
well we've got to just lay maxwell trial
and we've got all kinds of things so
there's nothing wrong with little
omicron to get everybody uh
here we go we had one very interesting
case a kid about six years old with a
temperature and a very high pulse rate
and i wondered if i should admit her
when i followed up two days later she
was so much better they're saying it's
increased heart rate a little
temperature
the variant could pose a danger a
greater danger to the elderly which is
every variant including the original
kelvin the fatigue is supposed to be
more intense there's more intense
fatigue
but we don't know right i mean how do
you have equipment
how long are we into this pandemic now
two years yeah coming up on two
this is the last one i think
and i know that we've been saying that
forever but
this is the last
i think this is the variant where at the
end
it weakens
the new potentially more contagious
omnicron variant of the chronovirus
popped up in more european countries on
saturday just after being identified in
south africa leaving governments around
the world scrambling to stop the spread
i love it
scrambling to stop this but the uk on
saturday tightened its rules on mask
wearing and testing of international
arrivals after finding two cases this
may [ __ ] up
our european tour our uk yeah uh you
know ireland and uh london london we
don't want it to i hope not in scotland
but
we don't know
we don't know what's going to happen
because
you know
you know i'm i'm not understanding this
i'm confused because
apparently people are rushing to stop
the spread of something that is
incredibly mild
i don't
but
you know we're gonna play it by ear it
may not affect us
omnicron
uh omicron omicron
what is the history of the name
why is it named omicron
pfizer and modern are like we'll just
cook up another vax
it's another trill
they kept naming the variants after
greek letters to avoid public but they
can't use z because that's the president
of china
wouldn't it be funny
i just want to see the ceo of pfizer can
we get a million dollar listing episode
of the 190 million dollar house the ceo
pfizer is gonna buy
in beverly hills
just the ceo of moderna
a lot of new pharma billionaire is being
created
i just want to see a nice episode of
selling sunset which has returned the
brain-dead women up the street
uh sell real estate and these two little
dwarf kings
um
are they own this real estate brokerage
these two dwarf kings and then they have
this this woman named christine quinn
who's the whole reason for the show
she's a lycan
google lycan
now a lycan uh is a mythological figure
um
and i think i'm spelling it wrong yeah
it's lycan it's something to do with
thor
lichen thor
it's a
she's a lycan well any event
ben will get that up
and uh she's like she's very tall and
she's kind of albino and she wears these
crazy outfits
and uh her and all the other women uh
fight with each other they don't really
sell houses uh the dwarf kings sell the
houses and
and then the women like uh
walk
uh
you know walk around these open houses
we went to a few open houses today
um but i just want a selling sunset
episode where just the ceo
of pfizer
goes and buys
what do you have there that's a like an
l-y-c-a-o-n and they're they're very
evil it says they're like half wolf well
no i don't i don't know that you are
really you're very bad at this it's kind
of interesting how bad you are looking
things this is from mythology i mean
you're like you're good at other things
but you're really not good at this right
i mean you this is and even people
comment this is where you don't really
add anything i don't shine well you
can't even get to what i'm talking about
it's very strange
that you you you can't even get to it
you're pulling up pictures of hyenas
this is from mythology
what about the movie underworld rise of
the likens
can you google underworld rise of the
likens please
thank you
hmm interesting do you see what i mean
anyway
the point is
these people you want to talk about a
flash mob
when moderna and pfizer when their ceos
start buying
houses
it's going to be
wow and i just hope i get to see it
i hope i get to see it
i hope i'm around
and alive to see it it should be soon so
hopefully i'll be here
um
just elaine maxwell they're now saying
she could win
how can she win
there are five ways i like that someone
has
said there are five
things jason maxwell can do to win five
ways jazlane can win her child
trafficking case as her trial gets
underway in new york these are five ways
okay let's count them down because
um
five ways this social age 59 she's
almost 60 could win her case as she
faces up to 80 years in jail on six
charges including sex trafficking of a
miner
okay let's see
scapegoat for epstein
so
she could claim she was being used as
escape gold for epstein well that's
a interesting
way to do it okay
that's number five
number four desire for cash
according to pre-trial court filings the
four women who had leveled allegations
against maxwell have received quote
millions of dollars from a compensation
program set up after epstein's death
they're gold digging [ __ ] that's what
she's got to say they're gold digging
[ __ ]
false memories of abuse this is one of
the good ones one of my favorites
leading cognitive psychologist professor
elizabeth loftus is set to argue that
maxwell's alleged victims may have been
influenced by media stories and
conversations with other accusers into
creating quote false memories one of my
favorites this is one of my favorites
they they trotted this out in the 80s
the 90s
they go no matter what happens if a kid
alleges somebody abused them they go oh
false memories
quote her testimony will concern the
workings of human memory the effects of
suggestion on memory the mechanism
of the creation of false memories the
characteristics of false memories how
memory fades and weakens over time and
how memory becomes more vulnerable to
contamination so you can easily be
convinced you were taken to an island
and you sucked alan dershowitz's dick
even if you didn't
[Music]
right to a fair trial now this one i can
understand maxwell's team could argue
that her right to a fair trial has been
scuppered
interesting word i would have said
compromised by media coverage and other
scrutiny following her arrest after she
was taken into custody william sweeney
the fbi's assistant director for new
york labeled her a villain who quote
slithered away to a gorgeous property it
was fine
um
age of accusers lawyers from maxwell are
set to argue that not all of the alleged
victims were underage
her accusers are listed as minor victims
one two three and four on the indictment
but her team will highlight that one was
17 when she was allegedly assaulted and
that the age of consent uh in the uk is
16.
and the age of consent new mexico is 16.
well i still think it's going to be an
uphill battle
for her
but those are that's not a a bad way to
do it
get out and you say these money grubbing
hoes
are trying to get money
also
they are
not telling the truth
they have false memories that were
implanted in their heads
i'm being used as a scapegoat
and if all of that fails
she was 17
which i love that's my favorite
they have false memories none of this
happened and she was 17.
so even if it did happen who cares
it's not a big deal
we wish her the best and you know how
was your thanksgiving was it good mine
was uh fine
it was disappointing you know i had a
bunch of friends over a few people you
know the thing is with these families
you got to get a real family because
these uh families that you cobble
together of these uh you know it just
you know it's fine but you wanna
you gotta get a real family in life you
know so it was a good it was good but i
i you know i can't
do thanksgiving with my family and i
don't want to i have no gumption to do
that and i never will again
um i might get my aunt i've there's
certain people that i would invite
separate from other people but you had a
lovely time lovely time played golf yeah
out in the woods yeah good time
yeah i mean that's good i just i have no
interest you know in uh in uh doing it
but i think i have to just adopt a kid
and uh get married or something because
there's not much else to do in life i
mean we've been relatively successful
with the show and you know touring and
everything like that but it's really
meaningless and everyone around you is a
kind of a horrible person so you just
have to get
another thing going and anyone that
doesn't have a family is crazy
anyone that doesn't have a family or
that thinks like it's uh not worthwhile
to have a family is kind of crazy
because
these
things you cobble together from p it
just doesn't work you know you need
you need a family you need that unit
whether you're gay or straight or
whatever you are
pedophile
which is lane max any of these but you
just need a family yeah she's close with
her family yeah
they're a family yeah
why doesn't seth rogen defend her
go what a boy is this a big deal
seth rogen was this
this is a big deal
seth rogen goes i've lived here for 20
years
i've never viewed my young daughter as
an extension of myself
who cares
i've never felt violated what's the big
deal
what that's what i mean it's easy to
defend like property crime because no
one cares about it why don't you defend
this
grow some balls and defend her like i
have
i've gone on the ledge
to defend this woman
and nobody uh will back me up
that's what casey neistat should have
tweeted
he should have tweeted i feel violated
that
that they broke into my car
and if we're gonna live in a lawless
society then free giz lane
how about that
i hope everything works out it's a uh
it's odd
it's been a it's been a weird news week
everything's been kind of dominated by
this
uh fake covet variant that uh is not
doing anything to anyone and yet
it seems totally fake you know fouchy's
on the news now and
again
he's addicted to himself
the thing with fauci tony fauci anthony
fauci he's addicted to himself
um
[Music]
you know he's the real pandemic if you
ask me you know the real pandemic is
fouchy vanity
vanity's the real pandemic and i'd like
you to pipe down a little bit is there
no one else that works
remember
is there no one else that works at like
the cdc can we get no one else except
him
is he the only czar
of coughing that this country has
is there nobody else that might
be a little bit more comforting after
two years with this guy
who's provably lied to us and has some
sketchy past with the gain of function
research like just from a pure casting
point of view sure is there not anyone
else is there nobody it's just this guy
again
can you pull up the um
interview that he just did
he just did an interview where he was
basically like yeah hey
uh this one on uh the the nbc one right
yeah meet the press
joining me now is the director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
it is dr anthony fauci and of course
he's the president's chief advisor on
coba dr fauci welcome back to meet the
press
so good to be with you
i did some
calendar math here uh exactly impressed
paul's labeled a variant of concerns
mildly amused anymore to be on meet the
press he wants to be on somewhere bigger
like that she wants fauci's not thrilled
with this
he's like hey man fine
yeah i'm here
the sunday chat shows yawn
let's see what uh dr fauci has to say
about um i'm omikron
in may
uh it didn't really hit us
until mid july and of course we had a
terrible surge there for about two
months here we are post november so
we are already experiencing a surge
now we have this
are we headed for a bleak winter here
sir
you know chuck a lot of whether or not
we're headed into a bleak or bleaker
winter is really going to depend upon
what we do
and i think what you're seeing is just
the manifestation of what we've been
talking about why it is so important for
people to get vaccinated and for those
who are fully vaccinated to get boosted
because even when you have variants like
this and there's a lot of unknowns about
this variant we know from experience
that when you get a level of protection
with vaccine and particularly now with
the extraordinary increase
in protection you get with the booster
even when you have variance of concern
you do well against them it may not be
as good in protecting against initial
infection but it has a very important
impact on diminishing the likelihood
that you're going to get a severe
outcome from it so this is a clarion
call as far as i'm concerned of saying
let's put aside all of these differences
that we have and say if you're not
vaccinated get vaccinated if you're
fully vaccinated get boosted and get the
children vaccinated also we now have
time
thank goodness that the south africans
were really extraordinarily good in what
they did
they were completely transparent right
from the beginning we were on the phone
getting real-time information for them
on friday we're going to be talking to
them again today
so we have an advantage of this we have
an up on it
with accents in the world south african
by the way the worst accent
of any
ugh have you heard of south african
accent ernie ells yeah uh it's the worst
more more information in real time
when you when you diminish or stop or
block travel from a particular country
there's a reason for that it's to give
you time to do things so don't let this
this uh
decision that was made
about blocking the travel from certain
countries
go without a positive effect and the
positive effect is to get us better
prepared to rev up on the vaccination to
be to be really ready for something that
may not actually be a big deal but we
want to make sure that we're prepared
for the worst and that's what we should
be doing okay why is what is it about
this variant that you've seen so far
that has everybody so alarmed that the
other variants that we've had in between
delta and this one
you know delta alarm folks this one
alarm folks lambda and move for instance
haven't what makes omicron so concerning
to you yeah
well right now what we have is we have
the the the window into
the mutations that are in this new
variant and they are troublesome in the
fact that there are about 32 or more
variants in that very important spike
protein of the virus which is the
business end of the virus and there's
about ten or more of these mutations
that are on that part of the virus we
call it the receptor binding domain that
actually binds to the cells in your
nasopharynx and in your lung in other
words
the profile of the mutation strongly
suggests that it's going to have an
advantage in transmissibility and that
it might evade
immune protection that you would get for
example from a monoclonal antibody or
from the
vaccine after a person has been infected
and possibly even against some of the
vaccine right induced antibodies
so it's not necessarily that that's
going to happen right but it's a strong
indication that we really need to be
prepared for that of that
together with the fact that it just kind
of exploded in the sense that when you
look in south africa so we we get with
the whole thing
the whole thing is like hey we don't
know this is the same thing with every
variant they go we don't know if the
vaccines are gonna work but get the
vaccines but we don't know if they're
gonna work but they might
and uh
you know it's everybody's best guess
right and uh
it's called omnicron and it's coming to
a theater near you
and uh
there's not much anybody knows that kind
of i'm sure they go around in circles
for the rest of the interview right um
you know like i said you know
i i lack
uh
the expertise and virology to know
anything about the new variant
i just from the doctors in south africa
they have said they're noticing in
extremely mild illness
and that there's not a
really crazy cause for concern
as opposed to
everybody else that's like shutting the
borders
and like
omnicron so
there does seem to be a little messaging
snafu
between the doctors going yeah we don't
even understand what's going on
and then people going hey this has got
32 mutations in the spike protein it
could have evade the vaccines it could
evade the monoclonal antibody and we
don't know maybe it will i don't know
but then you have people in south africa
going so far we've seen very mild
cases
and
so i don't know what to do we just hope
the tour doesn't get uh hampered
outside of the united states
of
uh
america the doctors are saying the
symptoms are mild
but i say
let's do a state of emergency first like
the governor of new york kathy hotel
shut it down i'm ready for another i
mean people yell at me when i say this
but i'm ready for a sabbatical i'm ready
to do a month or two in the desert
shut it
down shut it down
flash mob
let's do flash mobs
shut it down flash mobs
i don't understand the problem
with
taking a month or two of not working
the supply chain's [ __ ] anyway
nothing's coming in yeah you can't go
buy a couch they'll straight up tell you
it's gonna take a year you're out of
your lease at that point what the [ __ ]
the point
take a month or two let's shut it down
omnicron flash mobs
flash mobs
for a few months
get any of your friends and start
knocking over
nordstroms
for a few months
better safe than sorry omnicron flash
mobs
canada's indigenous health expert carrie
barrasso loses job and answers yuri
claims proven false and this is
something that a lot of people have sent
me it's very funny
uh what does she claim to be native
american and what was she russian and
how did they find that out uh she took a
test i believe yeah well
you win some and you lose some
that's great yeah why not
you win some you lose some
and she lost
yeah she said her name was like morning
star bear yep she's on bear clan she
said her name was morning star bear
swear to god right here
in 2019 she's a follower of owen
benjamin that's interesting
but this might have nothing to do with
native americans yeah maybe you're right
um
[Music]
i don't know what's going on
take her out and kill her
why don't you prove a point take her out
put a gun to the head
kill her
kill her let the omnicron get her
don't vaccinate her
omicron
flash mobs
i'm very excited that we're
two years after the into the pandemic
we're now entering the omicron
flash mob
part of this disease
which is perfect and beautiful
a scary sounding variant
accompanied with 30 or 40 people
pepper spraying
nordstrom's employees banging their
heads off the walls
and grabbing handbags
who said we weren't gonna who said we
were gonna come out of this stronger
because they were right they were
correct we came out of it much stronger
we came out of it 80 people strong
pulling up
outside the mall about to bang your head
against a wall to grab a handbag
omnicron flash mobs
i can't get upset about it i just have
to move you know i just have to go on
and
um
quote my name is morningstar bear she
said tearfully as the crowd cheered
i'm bear clan
i'm
and anishabi medes
from treaty 4 territory she proclaimed
as she described an impoverished
childhood beset by violence and she's
been full tribal regalia in this of
course great
she had a feather in her hair of course
she did
when i saw the tedx to be quite honest i
was repulsed by how hard she was working
to pass herself off as indigenous said
wynona wheeler an associate professor of
indigenous studies
wheeler a documented member of
manitoba's fisher river cree nation
started digging into barasa's
genealogical records and took her
findings to the media oh that's great
great this is a good movie no this is
good this is going to be like a movie
you remember like there would be
mysteries where somebody would take it
upon themselves to look into somebody
else yeah and they would find out that
they were like a murderer or they would
find out that you like you know you're
not the true uh
you know inheritor of the estate and
they find out that you're a liar and
now they're going to find out that
you're not a native american you're
really not it's like a mori episode it's
going to be the end of the movie just
ripping the feather out of her hair
at the end of tommy boy with bo derek
they find out that rob lowe and beau
derek were dating they're not mother and
son it's gonna be like this except
they're gonna be like you're not
you're not morning star bear are you
you're a dumb white [ __ ]
who says there's no good movies on the
horizon
well
we wish morning star bear the best
you are what you are in your heart
you know
now this woman's insane clearly
yeah god she's not uh not a looker
boy
well
don't move to austin folks i'll tell you
that much you're uh upsetting the apple
cart down there
there's morning star bear
how much you want to bet she moves to
austin
morning star bear you've got a home in
austin texas
university of austin come to the
university of austin and teach
barry weiss is
we've just added morning star bear
to our
to all of the
academic heavyweights
at the university of austin
maybe seth rogen will go who cares
i've lived here 20 years i can't tell
who's native american and who's not
what does it matter
i've never viewed someone's cultural
ancestry as an extension of myself
sometimes you'll get a nice treat like
someone who pretends to be native
american will give you a knife
it's fun
chad roger just defends every part
everybody accused of anything
right folks tim dilloncomedy.com come
see us live on the road we've got all
kinds of dates we've added second shows
in atlanta
sacramento go grab those and there's
still some tickets left for st louis
reading
pennsylvania uh all over the place it's
gonna be a lot of fun finishing out the
year strong here garden city idaho and
we have a late show as well in garden
city idaho so
grab that and then of course toronto on
new year's that is a big one at meridian
hall toronto ontario new year's a
massive new year show hopefully we can
do it with omicron
and then of course so far glasgow dublin
london
we are in the uk
hopefully omicron
doesn't [ __ ] us over and then huntington
new york at the paramount theater
shooting a special there uh in late
january and then red bank new jersey so
timdillycomedy.com for live tickets
thank you
so much omicron
flash mobs morning star bear